- [Announcer] This
program is a presentation
of University of California Television.
Your support makes UC
TV's programming possible.
Contribute online at uctv.tv/support
Check out our Youtube
original channel UC TV Prime
at youtube.com/uctvprime.
Subscribe today to get
new programs every week.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Welcome to a Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Theda Skocpol,
who is the Victor S. Thomas
professor of government,
and sociology at Harvard University.
And her two recent books are
Obama and America's Political Future
and The Tea Party And The Remaking
Of Republican Conservatism
written with Vanessa Williamson.
Theda, welcome to Berkeley.
- It's very nice to be here.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Detroit, Michigan.
Grew up in an industrial
town south of Detroit
Wyandotte, Michigan, where my father
was a high school teacher
of business education,
my mother a homemaker.
My grandparents on both sides
also grew up in Michigan,
Western Michigan, in Okemos.
- And looking back, how do
you think your your family
and especially your parents,
influenced your thinking
about the world?
- Well, my father Alan Barron
loved American history,
so I'm sure that I got some of
my interest in America's past
and American politics and the civil war
because he was a civil war buff from him.
My mother was a homemaker and they both
stressed the value of education of course.
- And was there a lot of
discussion about political events
and politics around the dinner table?
- You know, my dad was
the one who did that.
I remember walking with
him to junior high one day
and he explained to me
Keynesian economics,
so he explained how it
works, so I learned early on
that a family budget and a national budget
are not the same thing.
My mother not so much engaged in politics.
- And any teachers or
events that affected you
when you, before you went to college
that pointed you in the
direction of an interest
in political sociology?
- Well, I certainly loved my teachers.
I was an all A student,
which was not a very popular thing
for a girl in Michigan to be
at that time, a young girl.
When I got to college I got involved
in the civil rights movement
and that had a big impact.
I went to Mississippi with
a church based program
and that's where I met my
future husband Bill Skocpol.
- And what did you major
in as an undergraduate
and then how did this political activism
impact your education?
- Well, I was a Merit Scholar
at Michigan State University,
which meant that I was invited very early
to be part of the Honors College there
and that was a good thing
because for one thing
it let me meet very smart fellow students
from all over the country
and it gave me freedom
to put my courses together as I wanted.
I majored in sociology, but
partly because it was open
it would allow me to do lots of things.
I studied French literature,
I studied anthropology,
just whatever I wanted,
so I think that was a very
important that openness.
And the other part of it
was that it was the time
of the Vietnam War and
the civil rights struggles
and I got involved in
protests and demonstrations
and constructive activism
in all those areas.
- And what did you learn from that
other than the issues themselves,
you know that the war was wrong
and that civil rights
needed to be changed?
- Well, I learned the
value of getting engaged
with other people.
I think the the anti-war
movement went over the edge
and I did not go with it when
it went into violent protests.
But the trip to Mississippi
was formative because we
was a Methodist sponsored student project
where Michigan State students
went to a black college,
Russ College, and taught incoming freshmen
English and math skills, so I
learned kind of the marriage
of civic activism and
education I think from that.
- What about the women's movement?
How did that affect you?
By the time I got to graduate school
that was an important factor
and I remember getting
together with other women
in the sociology department
at Harvard University
to ask why it was that there
were so many women students
over the years, but none
of them became professors.
And so we definitely raised the issues
and I became one of the first women
appointed to the sociology
department at Harvard
after I got my PhD.
- And that was controversial.
I mean you were you were
a path breaker there.
- Well, I was a path
breaker just being appointed
and then a few years later
when I was denied tenure
after winning all the top
prizes in my discipline,
I filed a grievance about
that, not a legal case,
but a grievance and
that eventually resulted
in my appointment to tenure at Harvard.
That was certainly controversial,
but I would say that the side of me
that came out there
was sheer stubbornness.
I knew that I had done
what needed to be done
and I was I just simply hung in there
and insisted on being treated equally.
- Let's go back to your
graduate school education.
So you you were in sociology
and who did you work under
and what was your dissertation on?
- I ended up working
with Barrington Moore,
who's one of the giants of comparative
historical political sociology.
That was really a extraordinary experience
because he was a rigorous,
a demanding teacher
who asked you to write
papers that actually compared
big developments in different countries
across hundreds of years of history.
I ended up doing a PhD dissertation
on the French, Russian,
and Chinese revolutions
partly under his inspiration,
but also at the urging of Daniel Bell
and Seymour Martin Lipset.
These are all giants in
modern political sociology
- And that dissertation
was turned into a book
which became a major work in the field.
- Right, it was my first
book and it took a few years
after the PhD and it's
still regularly read
and sells quite a bit.
- So this passion that you have,
which is evident in that book,
and I'm not questioning its objectivity,
but something is driving your focus
on processes of political
and social change.
Talk a little about that.
- Well, I believe that the social sciences
should ask questions about
real world developments
and try to answer them with a variety
of kinds of research techniques.
So I'm not one of these people
who believes that you should just have
a data set in mind or
just learn one technique
of investigation and use that.
I believe you should ask questions
about change in the real world.
The first questions I
asked were about the roots
and consequences of revolutions
and my answers are quite objective
and sometimes they don't
satisfy political partisans
or even what I might wanna find.
So I don't believe in
ideological social science,
but I believe in big
question social science.
- And that first book, which I looked at,
really it's eye-opening in the sense
it brings added perspectives
to engage the debate
which was already ongoing.
- Right, I almost always
get involved in a question
because I think it's an important question
to answer about the world,
but also because I think
the previous answers
were not adequate.
So in the case of the revolutions book
I just didn't believe
that existing perspectives
either ideological or
social science were adequate
and I of course ended up
finding out that revolutions
that were considered liberal or communist
all resulted in
strengthening state authority
and frustrating the desires
of the liberal democrats
or the socialist democrats
that had started the
revolutions in some ways.
So that's one example,
but another would be
I got involved in the debate
about civic engagement
in America when I knew that
it was important to understand
what was happening to
voluntourism and voluntary groups,
but I didn't think my
dear friend and colleague
Bob Putnam's answers were quite adequate
so I had some other
hunches and a lot of times
I get my hunches out of reading
history, noticing patterns,
so I look at things big and over time,
but I also get down
into the nitty-grittiest
of empirical details.
- So if a student out there
would be kind of interested
in this way of thinking and
this method of doing research
what is the best way for
them to train for that
and to develop skills to
have this broader vision?
- Well, I tell students
for one thing you need
to be passionate about the
question you're answering.
If you're just doing something out of duty
or just because it's the latest squiggle
in some obscure academic literature,
you're not really going
to be very motivated
and you're not gonna have an easy time
explaining to other people why
your research is significant.
But beyond that, I encourage
methodological diversity.
I mean, I think it's fine to
combine quantitative research
statistical analysis with
historical investigation
and in my latest work I actually went out
and talked with people face-to-face,
so I'm a big believer in
bringing to bear all the evidence
you need to answer an important question
about society, politics,
and how they're changing.
- What are the qualities of character
that go with this kind of research
because you really
clearly have to question
the status quo of thinking
on a particular problem?
- Yeah, it helps to be
a little bit stubborn
and a little bit willing
to stick by your guns.
I mean I remember when
I was a graduate student
and I launched on the states
and social revolutions
PhD thesis, which was
really too big a project
for, you know, three revolutions
over hundreds of years.
That's too big a project for a PhD thesis
and I had people in my
department saying it was
and you should drop it
and I stuck with it.
Now, I had some professors
who encouraged me
to stick with it, so I
think that it is important
to have some support from your mentors.
But on the other hand, I tell students
if you've got a sense that
you've got an important question
and a new way to go about answering it
don't easily give that up
because really each generation of scholars
needs to do something different
and bolder than the previous.
If you're just repeating what
your mentors did, it's boring.
- Talk a little about creativity
in your work processes.
I mean is it, we've identified
kind of the the challenging
or the questioning of conventional wisdom
then bringing all kinds of data together
using different methodologies,
is that how the wow
moment then comes to you?
- Well the wow moment
is always in realizing
that I have a new question to ask
in a new angle to get at
it and that comes from
being open to all kinds of things.
I'll give you an example
from my second big project
which resulted in the book
Protecting Soldiers and Mothers.
I had set out to write a
book about the New Deal
and the development of the
American welfare state.
That was what people thought
was the American welfare state
you know, the social security
and unemployment insurance
created in the New Deal.
And I decided well, I better
go back and read a little bit
about what happened in the progressive era
so I have some background
and I was reading a book by
a man, Isaac Max Rubinow,
written in 1913 and he said...
he was comparing the United
States to other countries
and he said the United States
is actually spending more
on old-age pensions than
Germany and England.
I thought to myself hmm,
what could he mean here?
We all assumed we didn't start till 1935,
but he was a brilliant man.
He was very empirical, so I looked into it
and he's the one who put me on to
the civil war pension system,
which grew out of 19th
century American politics
and actually provided
disability and old-age pensions,
far more generous and far earlier
than a lot of other countries.
By following up on that
and taking the question
that came from that seriously,
I developed an absolutely
unique perspective
on the development of social
policy in the United States.
- And this gets into,
before we talk about the Tea Party book
and then the Obama book, this gets into
an interesting insight that it
emerges as I read your books,
which is the the reality and the truth
that lies in that reality
versus our ideas about what the reality is
so that in fact America is
a very conservative place
where the the ideology of conservatism
is almost the default position.
But people are I think
you say they operate
as liberals in a way,
talk a little about that
because it's fascinating.
- Well, you know, this I saw
in historical work I did,
but it's also known to
modern survey researchers.
If you ask Americans and I
suspect this would be true
at almost any era, do
they believe in government
or the free market?
They'll say the free market.
Do they believe in
government or individualism?
They'll say individual initiative.
Those are genuine American values
that I think almost all of us,
and I know I include myself in that, hold.
But if you ask Americans about all kinds
of specific things government does
to boost opportunity or ensure security,
they support those by
equally huge margins.
So that's the idea that Americans are
philosophical conservatives
who talk in those terms,
but are at the same time
quite pragmatic liberals
when it comes to what they
concretely want government
and the community to do
to help boost opportunity
and spread security for all.
- So what that suggests is as a researcher
your theory has to not only look at
the philosophical assumptions of the place
you're looking at, but also the reality.
- Yeah, and also you have
to be open to ironies
and to contradictions and not get into
so much of social sciences
based on the assumption
that you can slap one
paradigm on something.
Well that's not what
political life is like at all
and all good things
don't go together either,
so if you have an evaluative perspective
you better be prepared to notice
that some of the things you think are good
also have some worrisome sides to them.
- I'm curious, to work the way you work
it would seem that the
sense of the bigger picture
doesn't just come from
your own disciplines.
It seems to be informed by history
and I guess the humanities
because that's a place
where you find the bigger
question some time.
- Yes, I don't have very much patience
for purely philosophical discussions
or purely theoretical discussions,
but I always read history
and I have a sense of change over time
and that probably is
what makes me distinctive
as a sociologist and political scientist
that I've always been
interested in change over time
and suppressed possibilities
and comparing the past
to the present, comparing
different countries,
grappling with similar issues.
But I absolutely try to
keep the big picture in mind
at the same time that I'm
really trying to nail down
exactly what's happening
with organized groups
in particular, so I'm
not in the clouds at all,
quite empirical.
- Let's use your new book The
Tea Party and I'll show that
to talk about your methodology,
the problem you were
addressing, and so on.
So how did this book come about?
- Well, it was a surprise
book and that's another thing
I would always say to young scholars.
If something comes along
you're intensely curious about
don't say oh, I won't pursue that.
When Obama was elected president,
I assembled a group of
younger and older sociologists
and political scientists
to track what happened
in the first two years
to look at what this
change oriented president
was trying to change
and what happened and
what kind of politics
came out of his attempts.
Well, you know, not long
into Obama's presidency
was pretty obvious that
something called the Tea Party
had emerged and what was it?
A lot of people were
spending a lot of time
trying to label it either ideologically,
or as a social movement, or
a party, or this or that.
I was curious and at the same
time my graduate student,
Vanessa Williamson, was
doing an empirical project
where she was looking for
social capital in the tea party
and got to know the Tea
Partiers in Massachusetts
and went and observed
some of their meetings
and at a certain point we
realized that the combination
of the kind of looking at local meetings,
talking to local activists,
and trying to understand
how this fit into the big
picture of American politics
in the 2009-2010 period
was a fascinating project
and so we teamed up.
- And the, what was new
about the methodology
you were using here?
- For me what was new was
the the step that we took
of trying to make sure
that we went and observed
local Tea Party meetings,
not just in New England,
but in Virginia and Arizona ultimately
and that we sat down for one-on-one
open-ended interviews with
grassroots Tea Party activists.
Now, we had pulled together
all the national surveys
about what tea partiers were
like, what they thought,
what other Americans thought of them.
We had pulled together
electoral statistics.
We'd looked at the media and
its coverage of the Tea Party,
all these kinds of things that you do
to get the big picture
of an emerging movement.
We gathered information
on the Tea Party funders,
the group's funding Tea
Party public events,
in particular demonstrations,
but we knew we wanted to talk to people
because surveys will only take you so far.
I mean you can ask somebody
do you believe in government
or not and they'll say no,
but what do they mean by that?
- So how hard was it to
get people to talk to you.
Here you are, a quote Harvard
professor close quotes--
- Well, I really am a
Harvard professor and--
- No, but in their eyes
the quotes were for them.
- Well, Harvard professor
and I fit the stereotypes
that Tea Partiers would have,
which is that I'm a liberal.
Now, I'm a New Deal liberal as I put it,
but you don't have to click
very far on the internet
to find out that I'm a
publicly engaged analyst
as well as a objective scholar.
So, well that's quite a story actually
and it's another example of how
you have to be prepared
to go with opportunity.
Now Vanessa had already gotten
to know the New England,
the greater Boston Tea Party
and apparently because
they're in Massachusetts
I would say those Tea Party
people are open to researchers
and the leader actually let
Vanessa send out a questionnaire
an email questionnaire, so
we gotten evidence that way,
but we thought nobody's gonna believe us
if we just talking about Massachusetts.
We weren't sure we would
because do tea partiers
think the same in Massachusetts
as they do elsewhere?
How to get to know Tea Partiers
in other parts of the country?
Well, you know, I started
thinking who do I know,
what relatives do we have?
We sent some cold emails to
different parts of the country
to see if people would
respond and tea partiers
are very suspicious of
university professors.
In fact, they don't approve of them.
So finally I realized, Theda,
you know a tea partier.
I had been making comments on the website,
the arena website at Politico
as a New Deal liberal
and every month or so some angry white guy
would write me an email.
"You communist Harvard professors
who think you know everything
and can tell real Americans what to do..."
Well, I always answer them if
they don't threaten violence.
I answer, they don't expect
that, and so in one case
a man named Peter Stephens
in Gloucester, Virginia,
we had struck up an email correspondence
gone back and forth
arguing political issues
and sharing stories of our lives.
I've suddenly realized I know Peter.
Peter's a member of the Peninsula Patriots
in Gloucester, Virginia,
maybe, so I wrote to him
and I said Peter, would,
you know I'm a scholar,
I'm not just arguing with
you now, I'm a scholar.
We're writing a book on the Tea Party.
We already know that it helps
to talk to tea partiers.
I, you know, pressed a button by saying
we've already talked to
them in Massachusetts,
would members of your group be willing
to let us come and attend a meeting,
sit down for confidential interviews.
Well, Peter went off and asked the members
of the Peninsula Patriots
and they debated it.
We got to see them
debating on their website
because it's a meetup website.
Some would say no,
you can't trust liberal
Harvard professors,
another said well, we gotta
tape all the interviews
and I said well, fine if you want to.
I don't have the money to
do that, but if you want to.
And I told them the
questions we were gonna ask.
Well, ultimately they agreed.
They invited us down and
we had very productive
for more than a dozen interviews,
as well as attending the meeting.
- So what did you learn about
the tea party, who are they?
- They're older white, always
conservative minded people.
People who have either voted Republican,
they vote Republican against Democrats,
but some of them are very skeptical
of the Republican Party itself,
so some are libertarians.
About half are also
Christian conservatives.
They are deeply worried about the country
where it is now and where it's going.
- What surprised you most about them?
- Well, it was very moving to sit down
with the tea party people.
We ultimately did it in two places,
in Virginia and in Arizona too
and they were, the ones who
would agree to talk with us
were hospitable and really
just normal folks frankly,
middle-class people.
We know that tea partiers
are slightly more educated
and slightly more well-to-do
than typical Americans,
but that's mostly because they're older.
They're in their 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s.
Old people are the ones
who attend the meetings
in almost all places,
so I was surprised at their willingness
to be hospitable to some degree,
but I was also surprised
at what they really meant
by their anger about government.
After all, a lot of
people in their age group
are collecting social
security and medicare benefits
or veterans benefits,
military veterans benefits
and people who are perfectly
willing to acknowledge
that yes they were, and
that they had earned those,
just like all other Americans think that
about those benefits.
So what part of government
are you angry about?
Well, it helped to to
ask that and to listen
because it turns out
they're angry about benefits
for illegal immigrants,
who they're convinced
are getting health care
and education benefits
at their expense.
They're angry about lower income people
who haven't earned it asking for welfare
and many of these people don't
realize welfare has changed.
They don't, they haven't
absorbed that at all.
You have to work for welfare
now, you don't just get it
and they were upset about young people
and that was the biggest surprise
because so many of the
people we talked with
raised the example of
their own grandchildren
or grand nieces or nephews who they said
wanted something for nothing,
who were coming home to live
or asking for student loans
or maybe using food stamps.
We realized at a certain
point that these older people
didn't understand why these youngsters
were having a harder
time getting a foothold
in today's economy.
And of course, they often don't approve
of their moral views either.
The fact that young people
tend to be more tolerant,
tend to be not against gay
marriage, tend to be for Obama,
so they were angry at younger people too
and that did surprise us.
We wouldn't have learned that except for
the face-to-face interviews.
- And bottom line here, and
you emphasize in the book
it's really the other who
they don't, can't tolerate.
They feel didn't earn
what they're getting.
- Remember these are older people who...
watched an African-american
be elected president of the United States,
which I frankly don't think most Americans
thought that was going to
happen, so they were surprised,
but they were negatively surprised.
I mean the most important thing about them
is that they're conservative,
so they were upset
that Democrats swept the 2008 elections
much the way that liberals
in Cambridge, Massachusetts
were upset when George
Bush and Republicans
were wall-to-wall in
Washington DC in 2000,
so that phenomenon political
scientists know well
of when one party wins
everything in Washington,
the activists on the other side get angry,
and fearful, and mobilize.
Not surprising in a way,
but here it has an edge
of generational fear
of a changing country.
A country that's becoming browner,
a country whose young people don't feel
like they're behaving the same way you did
and that's what we
heard in the interviews.
We heard fear as much as anger.
Now public events you see the angry signs,
when you sit down with people you realize
that as they will tell you
I'm afraid for the future
of my country, that's how they put it,
I want my country back.
- You in a way, and I don't
wanna put words in your mouth,
but you are, you are taken
by the extent to which
the Tea Party is participatory
democracy at work.
These people organize their own meetings,
they were using the communication
tools of the Internet,
these were people who were
getting on the phones,
hosting events and so on.
So on the one hand you are impressed
with participatory democracy at work,
with their understanding of the process,
we're gonna elect this guy
and then we're going to watch him,
but on the other hand you say
they're completely ignorant
or wrong about the ideas that
they link to those processes.
- Yeah, I'll make two points here.
First, we concluded that the
Tea Party was not one thing,
so let's come back to
that because we see it
as a weaving together
of grassroots activism
which was quite genuine
with right-wing media
cheerleading as we put
it and a lot of attempts
by wealthy right-wing billionaires
to leverage this kind
of activism for purposes
they've been pursuing for a long time.
But the bottom-up part of the Tea Party,
the grassroots activism,
one of our questions was,
you know, are these people for real?
I mean where, we did a
web survey eventually
with two Harvard undergraduates
and we documented
the existence of 900 local tea parties
and we've got a map in the book
that shows where they were.
They're all over the United States,
so one of our big questions was who formed
these tea parties, how did they do it?
Did they just relabel previous groups
or were they new creations?
And for the most part new creations
and frankly that's very impressive
in early 21st century
America for any entity,
any movement to form almost
a thousand local groups
that meet monthly, sometimes
weekly, and depend mainly
on volunteer energy and
volunteer contributions.
They're not getting checks
from the Koch brothers
at the local level, so we wanted
to know how that happened.
We learned a lot about it
and we were quite impressed.
At the same time, a lot of
the content of what was said
in meetings or that people
said to us in interviews
was factually incorrect.
Now listen to the way I'm saying that,
I'm not saying these are stupid people.
In fact, they're not stupid people,
they're actually pretty astute.
They learned about the
political process in a way
that I was bowled over by.
I mean they would often
know what was coming up
at the local level at
their state legislature.
They called bills by their numbers,
only political scientists do that
and they knew who to contact.
They knew who to contact in a way
that even liberals in
Cambridge Massachusetts are
you know, they often
think politics consists
of the president giving a speech
and mentioning your issue.
These people much more savvy about,
they would learn the rules
of the Republican Party
and descend on a local meeting
and vote out the old boys
and vote in the new tea partiers.
They are good at the process of politics,
but they believe things
that were utterly amazing.
- And what in your analysis,
what you and your co-author are showing
is there is a bottom up phenomena,
but a top down phenom, talk
about that that interface.
- And that's where some of
the false beliefs come from
because for example, when
local tea partiers told us
at one point that the
government was preparing
to come into our homes and
takeover the thermostats
in all of our houses,
Vanessa and I are thinking
where did this one come from?
And so Vanessa went back
and watched Fox News.
Well there it was on the Fox Network.
The Fox Network has an older
white conservative viewership.
It is the primary source of news.
We ask all of our people
where do you get your news?
They all told, one guy smiled
and said where do you think?
And told us that it was Fox
and right-wing talk radio
at which these people listen
to six to eight hours a day
in many cases, especially the retirees.
Well, they're getting utterly
fantastic, conspiratorial,
and false beliefs from that
and that's been documented
in survey research too,
so that's part of it.
And the other part of
it is that there are,
once the Tea Party broke
out as a series of popular,
first demonstrations and then organizing
these local tea parties,
some long-standing
ultra free-market advocacy
groups like FreedomWorks
and Americans for Prosperity,
groups that have been
that have big fancy
offices, well-paid staffs,
they've been pushing the
idea that there should be
no taxes on millionaires and billionaires,
that there should be no
regulation of government,
that we shouldn't, that
environmentalism is a hoax,
global warming is a hoax,
they've been pushing these
ideas for a long time.
But they either relabeled part
of themselves the tea party
or they started appearing before cameras
celebrating the grassroots
activists or sending buses
to take them to demonstrations.
So they were leveraging
this and leveraging it
for purposes that include by the way,
privatizing the very social
security and medicare programs
that the tea partiers themselves rely on.
So we explore that
irony of the convergence
of the top down, on the bottom up,
and one of the main techniques
that the top-down groups use to influence
the local groups is to
send speakers around
that can be booked for
free by local groups.
- So there are two points
here that are important.
One is you point out that
when this phenomena emerges
at the grassroots and things are hopping
all over the country,
rallies, people in costumes,
and so on, that the national media
did not know who to talk to
and that at this point
when the national media
becomes interested they
have to have spokesmen.
So in addition to big
right-wing money coming in
to support these groups
with ideas and money,
additionally, suddenly, national
conservative organizations
said we will speak for
them and they're the ones
who go on the tube and comment about
what these people are really thinking.
- Right, and we document that that happens
increasingly over time.
At first as the local
activism is breaking out
it's mainly Fox News telling people
where they can go to hook
up with a local Tea Party
and putting a lot of
cameras on these folks.
Then by 2010 the mainstream media
becomes utterly taken with this.
I mean after all, I mean a
bunch of older white people
carrying signs denouncing Obama as a Nazi
and a communist, I mean that's photogenic
and they were beginning
to influence elections
like the Scott Brown
election in Massachusetts
and the Marco Rubio finishing
off of Christ in Florida.
The mainstream media wanted pictures,
but by the time you get to late 2010
and especially after that big election
where the Republicans win so big
with a lot of tea partiers
involved, they want spokesman
so guess who's there, Dick Armey,
the head of FreedomWorks, who has,
he's a former Republican
leader in Congress
and a longtime wealthy lobbyist
for right-wing business causes.
He appoints himself a revolutionary
and appears before the cameras
speaking for what the grassroots wants,
which turns out is what his
group has always been pushing.
- Now the second point I
think we need to emphasize
is a point that you just made,
which is there's a contradiction between
what the right big right wing money wants
and what these people actually believe.
They believe they've earned
their social security
and their medicare and
they don't want to take it,
they don't want it turned
into a voucher system--
- No they don't, in fact,
there's been national surveys
and you know tea party
identifiers are just about
ten percentage points behind all Americans
in wanting to preserve
medicare social security.
They are maybe at the 70% level
rather than the 80% level.
That's not very significant.
I would say that is a big tension
and one of the things we wondered
is whether it would lead to a split.
I would say it doesn't
partly because the grassroots
don't control the top, the
top doesn't directly control
the bottom, so what you
see politicians doing
and we should get to the Republicans here,
is trying to speak to the
primary concerns of both
and Mit Romney is a very good example.
I mean in the primaries he spoke to
what is the most visceral
widely shared grassroots concern
which is hatred of immigrants,
belief that many of them are undocumented
and that they shouldn't get amnesty,
they shouldn't get any benefits.
Remember, he went after
Rick Perry of Texas
said he was heartless,
Perry said Mitt Romney
was heartless for not wanting
to deny college access
to children of undocumenteds
and Romney went after him
and the tea party cheered
that on at the grassroots
and then Romney satisfies
the right-wing billionaires
by signing on to the Ryan plan
to voucherize Medicare and Ryan was also
a leading supporter of
privatizing social security.
- And but they put in the stipulation
it wouldn't affect people who are 55
which would relate to
what you were saying.
- Right, I think that
that's very important.
I mean I noticed that when the media
started covering Paul Ryan,
they didn't hone in on that crucial thing
which is they try to say it'll
only affect people under 55.
That, by the way, is not true
because once you take away
Medicare and social security
from people under 55,
they're not gonna wanna
keep paying the payroll taxes
that sustain people
into their 80s and 90s.
So that the whole thing
would come apart very quickly
and, of course, Ryan and
his supporters know that,
but it's very carefully crafted
to allow the Tea Party base
to not get too riled up
about it by saying to them
well, we're gonna exempt
people 55 and older.
Most tea partiers, especially
activists, are older than 50
and many older than 55.
- Let's talk now about your Obama book.
Obama And America's Political Future.
You are attempting here to deal with
the disappointment that progressives felt
with what Obama accomplished
in his first term
and you do that by relying in part on
an institutional analysis,
saying it's very important to understand
what's going on in the media,
what's going on within
the Republican Party
some of which we've just described
because the Tea Party essentially moved
the Republican Party to the right,
but thirdly about what
the state is like now
and what progress looks like.
- Yeah, I mean everybody was so taken
with the victory of Obama in 2008
and of course, he arrived
with congressional majorities
in the House and the
Senate for the Democrats
and he started seeing
these depictions of him
as the leader of a second
new deal, a new new deal
and sort of an assumption
that because the air
was an economic downturn because he had
these big majorities and
because he had campaigned
saying he wanted to
create a bottom-up economy
rather than a top-down
and had talked about
changing benefits and taxes,
that he was going to be
able to revolutionize
American government the way Roosevelt did
in the New Deal and that
that would be combined
with a rising political
majority because after all
he'd been supported by
young people, minorities,
the rising groups in
American electoral politics.
Well, two years later we
discovered that actually
he had changed quite a bit
and I'll get back to that in a minute,
but he wasn't getting
the political payoff,
so the motivation for the book
was to ask what happened here.
Did he really not change
things the way he had said?
Why was he not only enraging his opponents
but disappointing many of
his original supporters?
And why didn't the political
payoffs that you might expect
go with the policy changes he did achieve
like health care reform?
- And the bottom line here,
you talk about the term
I think it's submerged state basically
which comes from another
analyst which is namely
well, let's step back a minute
because where you wanna start
is with a comparison with Roosevelt.
And you, what you're saying is
Roosevelt's project was different,
although both projects are progressive
and it was in a different time
where there were different institutions
and tell us a little about that.
- So I'm using the,
instead of talking about whether it was
another new deal or not
in just descriptive terms
we, and this grew out of the
project that a bunch of us
did together as well as my own work,
looked at what it was like in the 30s
for a reform oriented Democrat to appear
with big majorities in the
middle of a economic crisis
and compare that to another time 2008
when the same thing happened
and the purpose of the comparison
was to clarify differences
as well as to see
what might be similar.
So we noticed several things
I mean the first and most important
is the economic crisis itself.
I mean Roosevelt comes to the New Deal
three years into the Great Depression,
25 percent unemployment,
people from both political parties
begging him to do something
and Congress passing the bills
before they even got
the written legislation
in the early period and
that's because the crisis
was so deep, so obvious,
that the need for action
was for at least a little while accepted
by everybody across the spectrum.
Look at Obama, he
basically is holding hands
with Herbert Hoover.
I mean he comes into office
just at the very beginning
of a financial meltdown
that's going to lead
to deep economic collapse
and unemployment,
high unemployment, but it hadn't yet,
so he gets involved in
trying to prevent it
from turning into a
second Great Depression
and that means he isn't
reaping the sort of
bipartisan support or
the popular understanding
of the need for many of the things he did.
So that's one, and another
very different part
is in context, hyper-partisan
by the time he arrives,
media that include a
right-wing media empire
that can get out a message instantly
while the rest of the media is fragmented
and he can't get his message across.
But you're pointing to the final thing,
which is it's a big difference
between putting in place
major reforms in government
for the first time,
people can understand what you're doing,
they may not support it,
but they understand it,
versus trying to change the direction
of an already massive federal government
that has its finger in
every sector of the economy
and that is providing benefits to some
and doing less for others.
And so we do a lot with that comparison,
I do a lot with that comparison.
- And if you take health
care, which you discussed,
that's really an example of a problem set
where you have vested interests
who can be very loud in in
opposing inner obstacles
and on the one hand who
you've got to deal with,
make deals with, pay
off in order to achieve
that your progressive goals.
And all of this is done
behind closed doors
undercover in a way,
because that's what the system has become.
- Yeah, and you know health
care is a very good example,
college student loans too.
In both cases you already
have the federal government
involved usually by providing
subsidies to private actors
to give things to people.
In the case of college
loans, banks were subsidized
to provide loans to college students.
In the case of health
care, apart from Medicare
and Medicaid, which are
government-run programs,
a lot of the way the federal government
has been involved in
health care in the past
has been to subsidize
employers with tax breaks
to get them to provide insurance coverage.
Well that had broken down,
so Obama did campaign saying
I'm gonna change these things,
I'm gonna give less to the privileged
and squeeze out the resources
in a fiscally constrained environment
to give more to ordinary
Americans more loans,
more grants to college students,
more healthcare to the
people who are uninsured,
millions of them,
40 million or so by the
time he came to office.
But to do that, he had to design
a very complex piece of legislation
that could get through Congress
that stepped on the toes
of many vested interests in both cases
who had the capacity to squawk,
they knew what was happening.
Hospitals knew if they were
gonna get less in payments,
pharmaceutical companies knew if they were
gonna be getting less for
their prescription drugs,
insurance companies, particular,
knew where this would challenge them,
but most of the people who
would eventually benefit
for example from health care, millions,
30 million Americans gonna get
secure health care coverage,
most Americans gonna get a better deal
from the insurance companies.
They didn't know what they
were eventually going to get,
so Obama ended up looking
like he was making
a lot of dirty inside deals,
the Cornhusker kickback
to get Ben Nelson to vote for the thing
and deals with Mary Landrieu in Louisiana
and it looked partisan and
it looked like an inside deal
and it looked complicated.
The beneficiaries didn't know what it was
because so many of the changes were in
these complex regulations and tax breaks
and the opponents knew
exactly what was happening,
so that's part of the reason that you get
the first two years
resulting in a huge blow back
from opponents and disappointment
from many supporters
who don't realize the enormity
of the Obama administration's
accomplishments.
- And this gets at what we
were talking about earlier,
the contradiction in the American system
where the ideology of
the country as a whole
is in one place, but
the reality is another
and it's bringing that truth
to the American people.
So they realize how they're benefiting
and then become supporters,
but then you go on to
say interestingly enough
that in many ways or at least in some ways
Obama failed as a communicator.
- I did, I mean we do talk about the way
in which the media environment
has made it difficult,
but particularly for economic policy.
And remember, the big
thing on Americans minds
by the time this president
took office in January of 2009
was the plunging economy
and Republicans knew
that they were going to
be able to run against him
and against Democrats in a down economy
because the enormity of the crisis.
Obama and the Democrats
sponsored the stimulus,
the American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act,
but they didn't do a very
good job of explaining
what was in it, why it
was expected to work,
and that was an enormous failure.
And that's a contrast to FDR,
who even in the darkest
moments of the Great Depression
was always explaining,
he was always explaining
what he was trying to do
and who was opposed to it.
Obama was facing solid opposition
from a Republican
leadership that had decided
that it wasn't going to cooperate
in any of these recovery efforts.
because they wanted to defeat
this president for re-election
and Obama kept trying
to reach out to them,
long beyond the time that was realistic,
but most of all he never
explained what was happening here.
So I think a lot of ordinary Americans
who we're now learning in
2012 are willing to give him
a lot of slack on this, are willing to say
well, maybe it did partly work
and maybe we should stick with him.
That's what's happening in this election.
That could have happened earlier
if only he had explained and he didn't.
- Did it surprise you that
he couldn't communicate?
- Yeah, I was surprised
because he obviously can communicate.
The question is what happened to him?
And I the only analysis I can
come up with is first of all,
he was overwhelmed with crises.
I don't think there have
been very many presidents
who have arrived in Washington DC
with more on their plate
because there's two wars,
one of which he was trying to wrap up
without a signing ceremony on
the deck of a aircraft carrier
or anything like that,
Iraq and another of which
was fraught with peril, Afghanistan--
- He has a very different
relationship to war
than Roosevelt did, the
war helped Roosevelt
to get out of the depression.
- Yeah, and he was trying to
wrap things up in these wars
or at least intensify
Afghanistan in some ways
and defeat terrorism and another,
so it was just a series of
crises he had to deal with
and then there's a economic
meltdown and he's a lawyer,
he's a constitutional lawyer.
I think he thought he needed people
who understood Wall
Street in order to both
recover the economy and
to change Wall Street
and regulate it, and so he
brought in economic advisors
who frankly did do quite a bit.
I mean we can all criticize
Larry Summers all we want
and I have a complicated
personal relationship to him,
but he did, they did take steps.
- Not enough.
- But they didn't focus on employment.
They focused more on stopping
the economic bleeding
and the financial collapse
and I don't think that Obama
had people telling him first of all,
that he should describe
the new investments
that were in the stimulus,
in new energy sources,
and job-creating infrastructure projects.
He should have concretely
stressed those things to voters,
so they could understand and
he should have talked about
why government spending
can help the private sector
because you can't assume that,
that stuff that my father
explained to me on the street
in Wyandotte, Michigan when I was a child,
Americans haven't heard any
of that now for 20 years,
so how would they know
that government spending
can actually help economic recovery.
And you had the other side saying
this is exactly the wrong thing to do.
I actually think they know
it was the right thing to do,
but they were gonna say it
was the wrong thing to do
and Obama didn't counter that
and I think that was a failure.
He himself has admitted
recently that it was a failure.
- And he bought into the
immediate problem is the deficit.
- Well, he into that a year
later and that is mind boggling.
I mean that's just the side of Obama
that wants to reach out to the other side.
- Now, which leads me to a point.
I guess one would have to
conclude that running the country
if you can do that these days is different
than running the Harvard Law Review
and it used to be said of Lyndon Johnson
that he would say let us reason together,
but then he would squeeze
you in a delicate place
to get you to move.
So stylistically, Obama has not evidenced
that part of leadership.
- Well, that's to some degree true.
I mean I am not of the school of thought
that we should be psychoanalyzing him,
but you're right absolutely
that people's backgrounds
do tell us something.
I mean it's both that
he came from academia
and that he's of his generation
and that he understands
that many Americans yearn
for a cooperative style
of politics, so these are genuine things
that a lot of people want
and Obama does try that.
He tries to bring people together
and get them to lay out their ideas
and then take some from every side.
I don't think there's anything
that's not admirable about that.
I think in many ways it is admirable
and so the health care reform for example,
contains lots of Republican ideas
and I know many progressives
and I consider myself
and my citizen capacity of
progressives would condemn that.
I think, you know, I'm not
sure we should condemn it.
I mean it was a formula for a broadly,
after all it's Romney's health plan,
so why not build something
that could get broad support?
But I don't think Obama was
prepared for the cold blooded
ruthlessness and the extremism
of the opposition he faced,
which by the time the Tea
Party was in the field
was also something that
Republicans were going to do
for their own life because
they'd be often primaries
if they didn't do it and I don't think
he reacted soon enough.
He doubled down in that second
year on cooperative efforts
and almost did in his presidency
because they almost sent
the country into default.
- You've taken in these two books,
the temperature of the
right's grassroots movement
and you've taken the temperature
of the Obama administration
and the progressive disappointment.
I don't want you to predict the future.
I don't think that's
something you wanna do,
but I'm curious, what do you think
we should watch for in the coming election
beyond the mistakes and
errors of Mitt Romney
you know with regard
to the these big issues
pointing to the country's
future after the election?
- Well, what we should watch
for is a good way to put it,
that's what historical
institutional analysis,
which is what I do can tell you.
Any social scientist who ever tells you
that he or she can predict
the future is blowing smoke.
I know the lot of them do,
but they're blowing smoke.
What we can do is tell you
what factors are in play
and what the alternative
possibilities are,
so the analysis that I've done,
which has been not just about Obama
and the grassroots Tea Party,
but about what's happened
to the Republican Party,
which by the way, has moved to the right
the furthest in quantitatively
recorded measurements
in political science for 50 years.
It's a breathtakingly
radical party at this point.
That means that this election
is one of the most pivotal
in American history,
it's as simple as that.
Should this radicalized Republican Party
succeed in taking the presidency
and both houses of Congress at once,
they will dismantle 20th
century social policy
within three months and
they know it's not popular,
but they'll do it anyway.
And so if that happens
we're going to be seeing
on the road to privatizing
social security and medicare,
we're gonna see, two thirds
of the cuts in the Ryan budget
are aimed at America's
already ungenerous programs
for the poor, we're going
to see devastating suffering
on top of the terrible
hit that lower-income
and middle-income people
frankly have taken
in this great recession,
we're gonna see disinvestment
in education research.
The federal government slated to be cut
to 50% of its level at the
high point after World War Two.
These are incredible
changes and many of them
will be carried through very fast
with no worry about any
filibusters in the Senate.
They'll just do it, so
that's one possibility.
Now another possibility is
that Obama's re-elected.
He has shown considerable fight by the way
in the last year, so
lest we say that this man
has no toughness in him.
I actually think when
pushed against the wall
by people he's reached his hand out to
have slapped it away,
he's one of the toughest.
The Obama campaign has been run ruthlessly
because they're working
to re-elect a president
in an economic slowdown and they know it.
And they know the stakes,
so they have not played
pussyfoot in this election.
If he's re-elected he's
gonna have to deal with
at least one house of Congress
that's under radicalized
republican right-wing control
and he's going to try
once again to come up with
bargains on taxes and spending.
He's going to be in a stronger
position for two reasons.
One, he will have been re-elected,
which is going to cause a
war in the republican party
that I expect to last for
about six to eight years
because they won't be able to believe it.
And secondly, he'll be
in a stronger position
because the tax cuts that
have taken such a huge bite
out of federal government resources,
the Bush tax cuts, are
going to expire by law.
So deadlock means they go
away rather than deadlock
meaning that conservatives
get what they want,
so Obama will be able to
say here's what I'm prepared
to bring back in the way of tax cuts.
Here's what I'm willing to change
in spending programs going forward,
you have to give on tax
increases for the rich
or they're going to happen anyway.
That puts him in a better position.
- Well on that note, we really appreciate
your coming on our program
and sharing your insights--
- Thanks for having me.
- Both about the Republicans
and the Democrats.
Thank you Professor.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(upbeat electronic music)